joining me now with reaction is David
Maury he's a former DHS special advisor
under the Obama administration and Ben
Friedman senior fellow at defense
priorities great to have both of you
here tonight David your old boss Barack
Obama largely won the presidency on his
non-interventionist message specifically
targeted at Iraq but in general that
America cannot overextend herself nor
should we try to remake other nations in
our own image so why do you take issue
then with what Trump has done here in
Syria well just like President Obama
wasn't exactly perfect in the withdrawal
from Iraq Afghanistan I think this is a
mistake
III agree with some of what you said
Laura I disagree with some of what you
said as well I think it was a mistake
because it's beyond contrarian in terms
of we've already defeated Isis I mean
the majority of the national security
community inside outside the
administration don't think we've that
this is a good idea to withdraw 2,000
troops from Syria that it opens up the
potential for reflash the general the
chairman of Joint Chiefs of Staff
obviously Secretary of Defense Mathis I
believe in Basinger Jeffy's Jeffries
special envoy McGurk you know this is a
little bit like declaring victory
landing on the aircraft carrier with
mission impossible behind you something
that presidents like you just look a
couple of months ago hey Ben I want to
get you in as a couple of months ago I
was reading all the headlines this
morning on the way down here and it was
foreign policy successes the Trump
administration Mitch you know mission
accomplished against Isis you know
obviously Isis wants to try to
reconstitute itself and here there and
everywhere so you're never gonna destroy
all of Isis but in the area where we
were focused Isis has been driven out
Ben I got to read somebody this is Mark
Tyson's tweet earlier today I love this
tweet and I get teasing big Bush guy he
said the following I'll put it up on the
screen he basically said here you know
anyone who criticized Obama's
irresponsible withdrawal from Iraq but
defends Trump's irresponsible
withdrawals from Syria and Afghanistan
needs to check their hypocrisy
your reaction there yeah I think you're
actually overstating Obama's anti
interventionism a little bit he was the
author of the surge in Afghanistan II
and put ground forces in Syria but I
agree with you on this we need a
definition of success or Isis's defeat
that mortals can achieve or the national
security experts that we're hearing so
much from complaining about this have a
standard of defeat for Isis that's
impossible to achieve it's sort of like
if anybody in Syria thinks nicely of
Isis or says anything in their favor we
have to stay in Syria forever so I think
we've achieved a reasonable standard of
success against Isis they don't have any
territory anymore they you know that's a
important thing they don't have the
allure to attract people to come idiots
from around the world to come fight for
them their ranks are decimated they've
been mostly killed so if that's not
success that nothing is and we're gonna
stay in Syria forever I want to play for
you just so our viewers remember what
Donald Trump said he was going to do and
his general approach to foreign policy
remember he gave his big foreign policy
speech I think was December a year ago
when he laid out his priorities like
principled realism I want to play this
and get your reaction let's watch a
leaders engaged in nation building
abroad while they fail to build up and
replenish our nation at home they
undercut and shortchanged our men and
women in uniform with inadequate
resources unstable funding and unclear
missions all right David that that's
what the president basically campaigned
on Barack Obama said something similar
but I think Ben's right realism on the
ground in Afghanistan kicked in couldn't
pull everybody out had a mini surge in
Afghanistan reluctantly deployed troops
in Syria he didn't want to do it you
know at the redline okay Trump smashed
him back on the red line of chemical
weapons used but look Donald Trump did
respond to these chemical attacks he got
criticism from a lot of folks when he
did
actually on the non-interventionist
right but he did respond so like Donald
Trump has done nothing in Syria so to
hear all these Democrats today say well
Donald Trump's just had a herky-jerky
foreign policy I think it's been fairly
consistent we said when we get it done
we're gonna we're gonna begin to draw
down troops because we have a lot of
stuff to do on the home front that it's
frankly not been done not been paid for
and we've got to take care of business
at home I think he's just fulfilling its
promise well let me say this I think and
Ben might can see this point in what he
wrote earlier today you know what gets
people worried is the lack of a national
security decision-making process I think
President Trump made this decision
talking to president Erdogan on the
phone so there's no strategy
communication scenario planning that
feels like it's in action number two
it's bigger than Syria just like
Afghanistan 9/11 was bigger than
Afghanistan what could this incubate
what are the ramifications for Israel
Iran there are a lot of questions there
listen three trillion dollars of
spending on Iraq and Afghanistan is in
some ways hard to defend from any
perspective from any party so I think
the issue is you know what do these two
thousand troops represent in to the
potential of a reflash and the potential
of a danger to the guys there is always
a potential for reflash that's why going
into these very difficult tumultuous
places with tribal factions you know
yeah Isis is a Sunni terror group that
Hezbollah is Iranian backed then you get
the ala whites with Bashar al-assad you
get the Christian community that was
protected by Assad and has been
destroyed and brutalized and persecuted
under under Isis and what's happened so
this is a complex web of relationships
and details and I think again the idea
that there's a great constituency been
for a return to Bush style
interventionism where we we establish
these beachheads and never leave i I
just don't think the American people are
Ford at some point it's gonna affect
Democrats and Republicans really badly
because you're gonna really get someone
in the White House who really doesn't
want to do any foreign policy of this
nature at all that will hurt us it's a
Beltway
Consensus I agree with you the American
people I think Paul show are not for
endless Occupational Wars it continues
to stun me the extent to which people in
this town look at the last 15 years of
American foreign policy in the Middle
East and say that went well I think we
should have another occupational war
using US military forces to manage the
sectarian Civil War for an indefinite
period in service of some management
goal it really continues to blow me away
that that's the sort of default foreign
policy thinking around here and there's
have been a lot of changes in the in
thinking it's there's some evolution and
look I don't mind when people evolve and
they're thinking I was the very rah-rah
the war in Iraq I love my I love our
trips went over there did a show there
for a week but after a while it became
fairly obvious to me it was a huge
mistake and many others okay so people
evolve they change but rachel maddow who
I think look she does a good job over
there at MSNBC but kind of confusing
where she's come down on this issue
let's hear what what she said last night
let's watch the way that US troops are
fighting Isis in Syria is in partnership
with the Kurds and carbonate partnership
with Kurdish fighters who are believed
by the US military to be the most
effective anti Isis force on the ground
and if the u.s. is now going to leave
what you're hearing what you just
described is essentially devastation for
the Kurds but then in an interview she
did on a for a book and Glenn Greenwald
treated this out earlier an expert
excerpt from this book called drift she
said in part we don't need a radical new
vision of post Cold War American power
we just need a small C conservative
return to our constitutional roots a
course correction advocating against
this almost colonial approach to foreign
policy I think the left is really kind
of caught in between you know two
different countervailing positions here
David and I think it's hard to square
the square the circle well I think that
foreign policy needs to be driven from
the center we might even agree on that
you know you talked about at the
beginning and tangling alliances I agree
we're against that it doesn't mean we're
against all alliances you know we can't
take our
allies and make them adversaries and I'm
not sure it's a great idea to take our
autocrats and make them allies you know
I think you know that's the challenge
that we have today I think this is too
too much of a dangerous world to be in
okay we're dealing with China right
China China we trade with China we do
technology transfers with China what we
got a Marxist Leninist regime so all
these people like oh we can't deal with
bad actors
what are you with bad actors morning
noon and night with China CEOs Hollywood
the media University so I mean we got a
we got a while do that real quick cuz
we're out of time SEC def any any pics
been real quick I can't think of anyone
who would take the job who I could
recommend for it all right David anyone
Bill Cohen he's not gonna take the job
either so that's not helpful
okay well mine is Jim Webb all right
mine's Jim oh yeah it's good I'd like it
or not I think it'd be a great choice
for my great great Navy and former
assistant secretary of defense yeah he's
my pick he would be phenomenal all right
guys thanks so much and